so i'm going out to dinner with my old  roommate from college i have not seen  her and for ever forever and i haven't  dressed up in forever forever so i'm  gonna take you guys with me  gotta wash the hair for this step  brushing out my hair  which dress black purple black purple  black purple i went with the black i  think it's pretty cute i don't know how  to do makeup at all but i'ma try is this  how you do it  please please don't roast the way i do  my eyebrows oh god oh god eye shadow so  bad at eyeliner that i really choose not  to partake in it i don't know how to  curl my hair so i'm gonna be  straightening it  okay so i'm ready to go  let me know what you guys think